hey guys how's it going so we are here
at YouTube live YouTube gaming you think
I'd get the name right since I've been
on this for a couple of times well we
are gonna be playing Mario Kart here for
the pre-show and then we're going
playing call of duty and we're gonna be
doing a special little segment with the
NES classic console which you guys saw
me unbox the other day so fan favorite
I'm not a fan favorite so why is there a
job awesome in this week serious okay
good
cuz I was reading the comments people
were very upset but there wasn't one hi
Ashley hi I don't really know I'm good
how are you so what are we doing today
we're playing uh we're playing some
games we're playing some Mario karts
we're playing some NES yes various could
be pretty excited yeah you're playing
call of duty i think i think i playing
call of duty wanna see we're playing
some of the campaign which depending
upon when I post this call of duty comes
out morrow or at midnight today today's
Thursday yeah guys watching
yeah exciting whoo okay who's your
favorite monocot character I usually am
partial to Luigi I usually ever says
Luigi's like my favorite where I've
never liked anybody say that I love the
weight like what he's so he lighted and
sad yeah I mean he's still weird I think
I started liking him Josh because of
smash bros ah that's really weird and
special yeah he does I mean he's just
strange I mean I love him too Luigi's
Mansion mhm so the whole vacuum I'm like
yeah I just get those ghosts yeah I
usually go for toad Excitebike is in the
game on this one wait oh and oh yeah
yeah this like this is mine this is my
wii u it's good it's all here okay good
Trustees favourite tracks is excitebike
arena we're starting with that one so
fun and it's a good toss to what's
happening in the show later you're
really good at my job
which is to say that later on in the
show we're gonna be playing the NES
classic edition we should all announce
who is whom just for people with pink
Yoshi
okay um she's I'm Isabella I'm getting
dressed I'm tanooki suit Mario I am
Lambie rainbow hair well today I learned
something about Ashley that I do I've
never asked anybody who their favorite
Mario Cart character is to play as and
have heard the response of Luigi
oh we just read though yeah sassy yeah
why are you not Luigi what happened I've
never played as Isobel okay and I love
her uh from Animal Crossing so I thought
I'd mix it up a little bit but I really
should have brought the weed you may be
doing better
who's that who's that in first place
guys happy home cuz I don't have to play
I don't know I kept closing further gets
intense Oh No Oh Mario Kart 8 I thought
I'd come in here check out what's
happening get ready for the big
lightshow hi Justine Maddox great to
have you back yes sir
lots of great stuff Kyle what down here
oh come on it's hard to me to hold
listen win at the same time all right
what's our final track we get one last
track tonight we go here we go what do
you want do you want to do my favorite
oh all right mount Wario is my favorite
track oh that's one where it doesn't
loot right it does no loot it's just one
trip down a mountain if you do like this
track host of the pre-show I'd be like
hey odd doing bad the sex I want you to
patronize us all right yeah I'm
pretending that you're not good at this
game I need you I kidding you Osmond
I'll take the pity okay what do you
think all this is my movie it was back
in the 90s cuz Gloria Morales Luigi
Mario I love that movie you loved it oh
my god like I jolly Bhuvana like honest
with us I bet but I think every time I
see him wait yes he's Luigi
he's a losing heart and he didn't phone
it in now he does he was a he was a
consummate professional you're only the
second person Justine that I've ever met
in real life with likes that move I just
three watches
three games you guys get to pick our
super C Double Dragon 2 or Bubble Bobble
Justine has already had a chance to play
around with the NES classic Justine what
do you think of it thanks Jeff so
yesterday I actually got this in the
mail and I was so excited I unboxed it
and I got to play a little bit so we
have it right here and I'm joined with
my friends we just can't get over how
small this thing is it's so tiny like I
mean for size comparison I mean you guys
get a shot of this like it's super
little I don't think it's a good
reference I was trying to take a picture
of it earlier I had a small bottle next
to it to see for scale look at thing the
pictures that they have of it holding
like in your hand I mean you can
literally hold everything in the palm of
your hand
what's great about it too is if you get
two controllers you can do two players
it does only come with one controller so
I feel like you're gonna probably have
some trouble trying to find a second
controller when they first come out but
ah it's we combine the pepper of our two
classic NES we did I brought my
controller over to the party it wants to
play some double dragon they do okay
okay let's do it let's see if we can
find it I can't believe there's no wire
the cord okay that's another thing
that's so short
someone's gonna mod some kind of like
Wireless regimes that's actually that's
stupid right because it now I'm starting
to think like Nintendo accidentally
making a whole a whole batch of like
small Nintendo's like cuz that's our
thing that is it so cute but it's just
like imagine like your Apple TV like
their remotes like tethered to it yeah
yeah you can get a super long HDMI cable
like we have here but like hot but
everyone's TV like your big TVs now so
you're not yeah asking it intimate
playing this thing I've already seen on
Twitter that people are saying that
there's all kinds of mods already for a
wireless controller while so that
clearly all right now we know having and
it sucks which is kind of cool I feel
like this is something that I would even
buy just for I'm sitting on my shelf
yeah it's really it's like you're cheap
right for 30 games built Damus yeah
there's a fantastic job how does it how
does it deal with save games you save
tell I'm actually not sure good question
that was a few cards had saving feature
on the old Nintendo so that's why they
had the passwords metroid had password
things zelda did too or no metroid
definitely did and that's why i am yeah
mom please don't turn this off yeah go
all the way through all mario alright
well the show is over it was super fun
and sad this would be my last episode
but there's still two more so next
Thursday and the Thursday after if you
guys want to watch on live with YouTube
gaming um where's my ladies my ladies
bye guys
what's up guys today we're checking out
the NES classic edition this comes out
November 11th so huge thinking intended
for sending news early to check out I'm
super excited even just yesterday my
sister was asking if I had a Super
Nintendo or anything here too